ほねほねザウルス100個分のパーツすべて準備することができましたー！
あのーすごい大変だったよ…
今日はもういいよ！
今日はもう俺が楽しめればいいや
やっぱ頑張った分ね、このほねほねザウルス100個使って
マジで最強にカッコいいドラゴン
マジで最強にカッコいい恐竜を作ろうと思います
すごいよマジ！どうしようどうしよう
何からすればいいんだろう
まずはこちらのね、なんか説明のに書いてあった
アハン、ハッ（笑）
アルティメット…
『アルティメットゴールデンドラゴン』
プププ（笑）
あーバカにしてる訳じゃないっすよ
まずちょっとこの『アルティメットゴールデンドラゴン』を作ってみましょう
パーツ数が膨大すぎてやばいかも逆に
あーやばいやばい
うおー
おーー！
うおー！
わぁ…
うわーーー！
あれ…
思ったほどかっこよくないですね…
いやいやかっこいいよ！
かっこいいけど
やっぱパーツがこんなにあるとね
やっぱこれを見ても
そんなにすごくないなって思っちゃいます
はいという訳で『アルティメットゴールデンドラゴン』でしたー
ハッハッハー
この程度で『アルティメットゴールデンドラゴン』か
甘い！！！
私はその上を行く
こいつをベースに
すっげえ進化させれる気がするんですけど
ちょ、まずこの状態からいじってあげよう
あの、自分で言うのも何なんですけど…
結構センスありますよ
まあ、ざっとこんなもんかな
先ほどの『アルティメットゴールデンドラゴン』を
僕なりにカスタマイズしてみました
…です
えっ結構かっこよくないですか？
あのーーー…
最高に楽しいです
あー僕こういうのめっちゃ好きなんですよ
昔からこういうブロック系が好きなんで
よし…
色々作ってみるか！
『デスアルティメットゴールデンハジメ―ンドラゴンGX 』は
ここでちょっと休憩
ちょっと色々作ってみよう
出来ました！
…です
かっこいい
めっちゃカッケ―
はい、このなんかバサッとしてる感じがすごい好きです
でなんかドラゴンにはですね
その下半身がすごい細いタイプがいるんですよ
遊戯王でいう
『クリアウィング・シンクロ・ドラゴン』みたいな感じですね
いやっ
かっこいいっしょ
はいという訳で
ほねほねザウルス100個使って
様々なものを作ってきたんですけども
オレが本当にしたいのは
この全てのパーツを使って一匹の恐竜を作ること
それが俺のオリジナルの
ほねほねザウルスだと思ってるんで
全部のパーツを使って
一匹のほねほねザウルスを作ってみようと思います
では行こう！
大事なのは感性とバランスだ
いかにして上手く恐竜を作るかなのでちょっと時間がかかります
えへっ
一応全部のパーツを使って完成しました
ギガデストロイヤーカスタム３６０V